[Música]
en la costa de áfrica occidental a tres
horas en barco desde el continente
se encuentra el archipiélago de villa
gosh en guinea bisseau
88 islas salvajes de sabana tropical y
arena fina
y aquí estamos en otro mundo
riccardo divina es el responsable de la
protección del parque nacional de orango
hogar de varias especies de tortugas
aves migratorias y cocodrilos
todas estas islas son un paraíso para
los animales
aquí el entorno es perfecto para ellos
el clima es bueno y casi no hay
actividad humana
y para admirar al mayor mamífero del
archipiélago hay que desembarcar en la
isla de impone
detrás del follaje en esta laguna
aquí está bien a refrescarse este
hipopótamo puede permanecer bajo el agua
durante más de media hora sin salir a la
superficie en la isla hay unos 15
especímenes
los dos hipopótamos están peleando no
pueden vivir juntos debido a la
competencia sólo hay una hembra aquí hay
dos machos no pueden vivir juntos solo
el más fuerte puede quedarse con la
hembra
algunas de las islas están habitadas en
el pueblo de el icog a los villa go son
autosuficientes
y viven de la pesca y la cosecha
todos venden sus productos en la
comunidad
recojo nueces de palma para hacer aceite
y venderlo para poder comprar arroz
recoger frutos de los árboles es muy
importante para nosotros así es como
ponemos comida en la mesa
los villazgo son animistas lo que
significa que creen en los espíritus del
bosque y del mar tomar de la naturaleza
sólo lo necesario para sus necesidades
es la regla de oro establecida por las
sacerdotisas y estas mujeres tienen el
poder en la isla
la naturaleza es un poco como la tienda
del pueblo así que lo prohibimos a
nuestra comunidad sobre explotar
nuestros recursos naturales
tenemos que gestionarlos para que duren
para hacer cumplir estos principios los
guardias del parque hacen patrullas esta
es una zona protegida desde
1996 y sólo se permite la pesca a
pequeña escala por parte de los isleños
pero aunque estos mares están llenos de
peces también están llenos de pescadores
furtivos
tenía capital
y
el capitán es multado y su permiso de
pesca es confiscado
y sé que es una zona protegida pero es
el único lugar en el que todavía hay
peces así que me arriesgue y este es el
resultado ya nada
también que luego ocurre poco atrás
llenar
incluso por la noche de las patrullas no
se detienen
los guardias deben llevar luces rojas
para no asustar a las tortugas esta isla
es uno de los mayores lugares de
anidación de tortugas verdes del mundo
cada año estaban aquí 27.000 nidos
cuando termine de poner los juegos
cubrirá todo para tratar de camuflar el
lugar para que ningún depredador los
encuentre
tres meses después las crías de tortuga
se abrirán paso intentarán llegar al mar
sin ser atrapadas por los cangrejos que
las esperan las islas villa bosch son un
paraíso donde el tiempo parece detenerse
gracias a todos aquellos que luchan por
protegerlas
[Música]